le documentaire citizen fort
présentement à l'affiché dans lequel on
peut voir le lanceur d'alerté eduardo
dun révéler les désormais célèbres
programme d' écoutes de la nsa comporte
plusieurs aspects renversant dans son
match sur ce lieu alors il parmi ces
aspects là il y a ce qu'on voit dans le
documentaire la construction la de ce
méga centres de données au niveau de la
construction il est maintenant terminée
il a été inauguré il ya un an
c'est le plus gros centres de données au
monde qu'est ce qu'on y fait mais
imaginez c'est un immense disque dur en
fait le plus gros disque dur jamais créé
de l'histoire d'humanité je vais vous
donner un ordre de grandeur imaginer la
bibliothèque du congrès à washington
on trouve là dans 32 millions de livres
61 millions de manuscrits un million
publication gouvernementale
un million de journaux 500 à 1000
microfilms 5.3 millions de cartes 6
millions partition 3 millions
d'enregistrements et bien ça ça prend
une minute pas enregistré 7 qui va leur
donner là dans le centre de bluff
d'ailleurs aussi massif si c'est énorme
c'est lui de quel genre de données par
le ton des émissions télé probablement
que nous sommes actuellement
enregistrées en août alors on les salue
il ya aussi des évidemment les courriels
des transactions bancaires des appels
téléphoniques dont tout ce ce qui rend
possible soit céline c'est le coût des
données imaginer j'apporte une clé usb
ici de 2 gigaoctets cinq ans disait
qu'on connaît il ya 30 ans est lé là
aurait enregistré l'équivalent de 600
mille dollars de donner 2 gigaoctets ça
va les six cent mille dollars
aujourd'hui s'est dissous donc c'est à
gérer le mic de ficher les gens
ce qui n'empêche pas quand même ce
central d'avoir coûté plus de 3
milliards de dollars à la construction
et les équipements et de consommer
l'équivalent 65 mégawatts par jour c'est
l'équivalent d'une petite ville et
surtout 6.5 millions de litres d'eau
pour leur refroidissement des
ordinateurs et pourquoi alors ce disque
dur fait autant parler et jaser parce
qu'on veut lui couper l'eau alors
actuellement il ya vraiment là une
coalition de gens de gauche comme de
droite des républicains des démocrates
des environnementalistes également
qu'ils en ont contre ce fichage
généralisé qui est réalisé par le
gouvernement fédéral est le seul moyen
qu'on a trouvé de pouvoir empêcher ça
c'est de faire passer une loi dans une
loi qui est à l'étude actuellement la
législature de l'utah et qui
empêcheraient en 2021
municipalité de vendre de l'oua ses
centrales parce que vous savez
qu'actuellement la ville de bluff dell
aurait conclu des ententes secrètes avec
la msa pour vendre de l'eau à rabais
mais ça a quand même coûté 3.5 millions
de dollars à la municipalité pour
raccorder ce centre de données
gigantesque aile à son réseau d'aqueduc
et là les gens disent écoutez dans une
dans une région où il ya beaucoup de
sécheresse qu'est ce qui va se passer si
jamais un moment donné on à choisir
entre les résidents et le centre de
données
alors ça pose énormément de questions et
les gens qui veulent m'en se disent les
défenseurs des libertés civiles les
environnementalistes les gens du parti
républicain et les gens du parti
démocrate
ben c'est soit c'est soit ça ou se faire
espionner par le gouvernement fédéral
alors on est déjà choisi son camp en
tout que le débat fait rage actuellement
s'inquiète beaucoup de gens s'inquiètent
bien les gens à gauche comme à droite
merci beaucoup nous en avoir parlé
mathieu plaisir